there's a lot of talks about open
relationships right now
yeah what is this story with open
relationships i think that that is sort
of the the
adaptation that's going on right now
because a lot of like as you were just
looking at the traditional marriage like
where's one man one woman they get
together they have two kids in a you
know golden retriever in the front yard
right um
that is a dying model that is an old
order model it's a 20th century model
today in the
21st century in the social media era
women are exposed to uh what is it the
paradox of choice right it's they all
you have to do is go on your cell phone
and go on tinder and like you got
there's far more guys on tinder than
there are women on tinder so this sort
of gives this idea that women are have a
higher
a higher threshold when it comes to like
well attention or when you know from
from other guys
um so there is the idea anyways this is
this is the in theory anyhow is that
paulie is an adaptation for the um the
situation that's going on between like
what used to be just sort of the nuclear
family right now so when a woman for
instance when a woman when we're talking
about poly poly works differently for
both guys for for men and for women so
when we think of poly we think of one
guy who's like yeah man i got i got
three girls here you know this is great
you know they but guys want to have that
variety you know they want to have like
the three ways or whatever it is
um the common fantasy that so we think
of paulie in those terms but when we
look at it in a modern sense polly
really kind of comes down to who's the
most attractive and who can leverage it
the most in today's society it's women
that can leverage it the most because
they're the ones that get the most
attention online in a social social
media pers you know perspective again
going back to those stats uh i had them
here just a second ago but it was uh if
you look at how couples met over the
from like 1950 all the way to 2020 and
you look at like friends and family
school church whatever else it is and
you look at just like how low those
numbers are right now and there's one
huge spike right now and maybe you'll
pick he'll pick it at that huge spike
right there that's online dating and
that is like not that's only in like the
last like 15 to 10 to 15 years right
there
that is what i'm do you want to know why
paulie is so popular that's why polly is
so let's look at that let's look because
of online dating
well because of choice because or even
just the the presumption of choice
and i'm sure that's even higher because
that's 2017. yeah so through friends
33 to 20
bar restaurant
went from 19 to 27 so that one higher
i'm sure it's lower for kovit because
ain't nobody going to bars or in covet
right at work it went from 19 to 11
percent does that mean people are no
longer working
school college from 19 to 9
through family 15 to 70 wow so they're
no longer going to thanksgiving you know
so so
going back to what we're talking about
with uh
this whole thing about availability
right we looked at a stat a couple
months ago if you remember the stat
where
the percentage of folks who were getting
married online
versus through family it was seven times
higher do you remember that stat it was
do you remember that stuff we talked
about there's an article we covered
people that meet online are more likely
to get divorced and and people who meet
through friends or family are the most
likely to stay married yeah so people
who meet online are more likely to get a
divorce and people who meet through
friends and family and i think friends
and family was the highest if i'm not
mistaken right friends and family and it
was work why do you think that is why do
you think divorce is higher for online
than friends and family okay well again
it's uh you're spoiled for choice that's
that's first and foremost um you have to
look at the people well that's the one
that's actually what i was looking at
right there
if you look at that spike that really
dramatic spike right there that's and
when when did that start right around
2000 i can't see it from here 1999 1999
all the way up to where we're at right
now uh i i all chat as well i see a lot
of i see a lot but is that
groundbreaking that's like saying no no
social media is where people are are
doing what they're talking about
is tv wasn't what he's saying is
availability
our understanding our expectations of
marriage our expectations of forming a
relationship are based on
pre-2000 standards i'm gen x your gen x
i believe
but even if you're millennial right now
you're still you still remember an age
in the 90 if you watched an episode of
friends that's old the old order way we
used to do we used to do relationships
we still have this expectation this
ideal of this 20th century model for
relationships in an age where we look at
a dramatic spike like that in how people
meet online and again you have to also
you can't just take that one data point
and and just like say this is it yeah
there's all other interrelated data
points that go along with that you're
also looking at men who are falling out
of you know the lost boys generation the
guys who are not getting laid right now
because they it's i'm looking at the gss
study right now men are far more sexless
today than at any other time in in
history any other generation in history
well it is it's in cell concept but it's
also statistically a reality my friend
david's dealing with right it's like 28
right
i just read this thing is 28 percent of
men below the age of 30 are sexless
they're they're still either virgins
what was that number again 28 of men
below the age of 30 you know up to 30
are sexless what can those guys do is
this some of the big the triad make more
money yeah money muscles game yeah and
and i mean that's if you want a
prescription that's what i would that's
where i would go to however that data
point set against this stuff you're
going to ask me why is poly a big deal
why is it now where we're not getting
married why is uh well of course divorce
rates are lower now as well because
nobody's getting married
um and so we're looking for alternatives
to that right now we're looking for uh
alternative ways of forming families and
i think we're kind of doing a poor job
of it right now because we're still
thinking that we can get back to this uh
you know 20th century
model for relationships in an age where
28 of men below 30 aren't aren't getting
any and we're looking at how are they
how are they finding each other okay
also look at how what are the what's the
demographics and what is the uh what are
the numbers of men versus women on those
dating apps to begin with it's mostly
men and uh like an ocean of men and like
a very few select set of women who are
getting those responses so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]